welcome to this video will love life I
wonder what this flag martinique okay so
not a very high probability that i
really knew at once but forgot i was
thinking okay I knew this but I forgot
what it is but they're not really never
knew what the Martinique flag life is
like okay somebody's free stuff it's not
a very common line not that bad though
can be recommended if you want something
offbeat against the Sicilian okay give
me that Bishop okay taking on these six
felt was a bit more challenging yeah the
c5 pawn of course can be a problem this
is somewhat similar to positions out of
the news oh
but it's not that easy to win I mean
it's not entirely simple ok let's go
forward ok so if i take here you wants
to take with the jeep on this is that
great hard to believe let's take it ok
can remind him that a 4 is an idea as
well if he goes a for himself rupee aid
ok so i will get counter play here ok
bishop h6 i should react and eight or
look age I think will be eight is
simpler
yeah now you know he has to give me be
three on Play 92 which doesn't look very
appealing so 96 this is idea yeah the
question is what about f 6 cm efg takes
loses the bishop let's not that there
should a forum area that could be tricky
nap not clear
yeah but it pretty much has to go Fisher
therefore I really don't see anything
else why am I playing g5 then it would
be an immensely brutal move man that's
not going to do five it's not going to
work I wanted to go f5 Bishop f4 f5 96
Queen evade something like that
threatening g5 maybe yeah okay let's not
think too long oh wow how I allows me to
take the side didn't consider at all
seems to digitally very risky age sixths
not really a thread down anyway let's
have a look at that f pawn and can go
boo should be 76 this was where I was
headed my god hesitated hesitating a
little bit because i'm not sure if
Bishop to yourself he's helping him or
not
night x5 it's not doing which takes
Queen of three root g two not really
yeah I was actually thinking just just
push it away this a move or not let's do
it
hey Luke a wonder maybe just root K 1
and sorry look BA 2 this is what I'm
talking talking about
it's really not ideal we're taking me
five now NT three but it looks very
shaky well now I can take our leaf or
not and now night night here threatening
night f2 I have come on chief form does
g4 win takes ok let's do it I thought
this should win somehow f3j Queen takes
Knight you one King takes Queen f7 and
this one no thing here to believe that
make baby time margin yeaaaaa h5 this g5
where it's the maid here and then have
to play
so that's sick and losing control over
this position after this I after having
this very nice position what is going on
here 93 may be still bishop moves my
deaf Torchic Brooke check is not doing
that much check
check check check check I'm just a board
game drawn yeah of course I must win
this position unbelievable here I didn't
see a window just bad they're here I
must win it and this is winning I a
Queenie force to simply winning a very
simple as usually it's very simple stuff
I see that move and now who I don't see
anything yeah now I mean rook g7 is
winning but this is not like super
trivial biquini for is very trivial
check queen of three years over and just
for yes no move yeah Group chief for the
win he obsesses also when Kings you
wanna check but here this is really only
this one chat it's not that's not that
easy Dunham Jay and his he's running
into fork hi tricky very complicated
game anyway and she should be five or
six then look good share some so kind of
improvement here would be nice I f4 was
a good move that's not bad right I know
it's not bad yeah this isn't is this
should lose but I couldn't punish it
okay well thanks for watching